okay so we're gonna play d4
and i'm gonna play a london system so i
know that a lot of people oh i should
get my notebook ready
i know that a lot of people do play the
london
and uh i i'm sensitive to that so let's
play a couple londons
all right where's my charlotte chess
center pen oh my god i didn't even come
prepared this is ridiculous
i can't i can't play without my pen
okay it's fine i'll just play without my
pen okay so
[Music]
we're going to go knight c3 here and
transpose them to the jabal london
um i've done that several times now
you guys already know the drill uh this
knight can potentially go to b5 but we
don't want to go knight b5 here
knight b5 here would be bad for what
reason who wants to tell me
why is knight b5 innocuous after bishop
f5 that's why he played it correctly
because of what specific move uh not
queen a5 because of c3 but rook c8
and it's not actually the check that's a
muppet that's the most popular wrong
answer
so now what we're going to basically say
is
we want control over this diagonal now
what is blocking bishop b5 from being a
check
the knight on c6 how do we get rid of
the knight on c6 we slam our knight into
e5 that is one of the key ideas
of the job london the move 95. now there
are several ways to think about this
this bishop on f5 is actually
in more trouble than it may appear and
what idea if you guys have been
attentive to my actual games
what idea does white have which exploits
the
hidden vulnerability of this bishop it's
actually a henrik
on the ball g4 and h4 and the thing is
it's not that black loses the bishop but
black may have to go h6
and if the bishop is on g6 and the
knight is on e5
then knight takes g6 forces f takes g6
which is actually tremendously awkward
okay so we're actually kind of spoiled
for choice here let's actually see how
this works
g4 let's actually see how this works
uh i had a really really cool game which
happened which went exactly like this
over the board game which where i beat a
gm
yufa daniel yuffa 2500
and this causes a lot of problems for
black there's a lot going on here
there's a lot to unpack but
everybody should see that the bishop is
being attacked right now okay
now black has a complicating move here
which may seem to offer a solution to
black's problems
what am i talking about here what move
seems to offer black a solution to the
problem of the bishop
it's kind of an interest it can be
thought of as an intermediate move the
knight takes e5 right
and the thing about knight takes c5 is
that after knight takes c5
d takes e5 if you look very carefully
both the knight and the bishop are
hanging but black can play knight takes
g4
but at the very end of that line don't
forget about the main idea of the move
95 what move becomes possible
one move becomes possible at the end of
that line i'm asking you guys to do some
visualization here not easy
but what i'm asking you guys to
visualize is knight takes d takes
knight takes g4 bishop b5 check is
devastating because there's nothing to
block that diagonal the king has to move
out to e7
which is actually quite devastating 250
thank you
and uh that is just absolutely
devastating when the king moves out to
e7
in the opening that's generally not a
good sign unless there's extenuating
circumstances now of course
we play the typical move f3 attacking
the bishop forcing it back to g6
so i'll explain everything after the
game i'll show everything on the board
don't worry guys if you're having some
trouble visualizing
this is let me grab my pen in the
meantime
so bishop g6 h4 that is
the bottom line and here we go h5
so now we play knight takes g6 now how
do we
how do we exploit the fact that the g6
spawn is weak
how do we exploit this
let me just write some stuff down
yeah bishop d3 is correct thank you
marco barr
bishop d3 is correct bishop d3 attacking
the pawn
and of course knight takes d4 is not
possible now
knight takes d4 is actually not really a
threat because bishop takes g6
check exposes the attack of the knight
so the way that we need to think about
this position okay how do we
how do we arrange our pieces here what
what needs to be done
in such a position in order to increase
the pressure and what we need to not
lose sight of
is the fact that we haven't completed
our development and in order to complete
our development
and this is a concept that i'm going to
flesh out after the game we're going to
go g5 here which is not an intuitive
move
why am i closing down the position when
it may appear
white is the one attacking the reason
i'm doing this is in order to give
myself a little bit of time that i'm
going to use to prepare castling long
so here we're going to go queen to d2
remember that knight takes d4
is not worrisome i can actually just
ignore that move entirely
can i ignore this can i castle here is
it possible to castle
do or do we need to deal with this do we
need to take the bishop
yes or no yes says nanuka
no no that's why we put the queen on d2
now
we bring the rook into the game final
piece comes into the game
let's get rid of the knight and now a
very typical winning move this move
crushes
when we have a pawn on g5 pawn on e6 is
weak
very thematic this kind of should be
automatic to you guys in many of these
positions
boom goes the dynamite isolating the
king is the second worst defender after
the queen
right the king is a very bad defender of
anything because it can be easily
attacked and a check
needs to be dealt with by definition now
if the king tries to cling to the pawn
into one of these two moves
what follows king f6 or king e7
meets with what response and that of
course is you guys
your tactical detector should all be on
high alert in this position anyway
and the fact that the king steps into
the same diagonal as the queen should
also be
something you pay attention to yeah sexy
car is in the
is in fact in the chat and now we play
rook takes c6
okay rook takes c6 now look at this uh
scenario this is also something that
should alert our metal detectors
because uh what we should notice here is
the fact that a
mate on ea is actually very likely we
already have some sort of distraction
sacrifices which may help deal with that
so what move helps um orchestrate helps
in
helps create the possibility let's say
for the background maybe that is of
course to double the rooks
now um we don't need to overthink things
all we need to do is simply collect the
harvest
as they say in russian let's take on d5
no need to do anything absolute no need
to do anything outlandish in such a
position we simply want to improve our
pieces
until an opportunity to win the game
kind of naturally presents itself
okay how do we go about winning this
position who can propose
a simple way to improve our position
and what i propose is to play this
gradually and slowly rather than do
anything crazy or
alternatively we can sort of try to
understand okay let's think logically
how do we get our rook to e8 let's
create the item on our way
we need an item on our wish list our
number one item on the wish list is to
get a rook to e8
and we know that we need to employ for
this task the least valuable piece you
guys are making the same mistake of
employing the queen
but we can actually employ the knight we
can go knight c7 and the reason this is
better than queen e3
is because we actually win black's queen
that's the reason why involving the
queen isn't such a good idea
because ultimately we're going to
capture with the queen and offer a queen
trade we don't want that we want to
win black squid not trade it
i hope that makes sense uh this is a not
an easy concept to fully explain
but you guys can see it applied quite
frequently here
okay this no queen f5 does not work and
i'll show that after the game
it comes close to working but it doesn't
it comes close to working but it doesn't
no rookie immediately you are insane
unfortunately you are insane
97 he would have just taken i wasn't
sure that 97 is the fastest win
97 takes takes and why is 97 so good
then he takes on g6 i'll show this after
the game guys
people are overestimating 97 check
resigns okay
okay so we get a jabba london right
knight c3
bishop f5 first point why is knight b5
not dangerous here
um i know that most people are attracted
by this move but be careful about this
move in general
um queen a5 doesn't actually win the
knight the knight is defended
so when we move the knight out of c3 we
can simply play the move c3 which by the
way is a helpful move regardless
the move c3 creates a pawn chain
and protects the d4 bomb we don't want
to help white play this move and the
queen on a5 is kind of offsides think of
a soccer player
that's kind of offsides so the way to
actually protect against knight c7 is to
go rook c8 literally to defend the
square
and if you compare this to a scenario
like this
the main difference is that the move
rook c8 is not possible that's why you
need to get this bishop out of the way
okay and black's next move is just going
to be a6
kicking the knight away from b5 knight
c7 check
just to be very clear two pieces for a
rook is not good for the side that gets
the rook in just a regular middle game
unless there's an extenuating
circumstance okay so this doesn't
actually work for white
there's no way to enhance white's
control of the square
oh silo simon with a thousand bits
thanks man and thank you for all of your
support engagement
valued member of the community silo uh
thank you so much man i really
appreciate you
and uh thanks for the thousand bits
always welcome
enriching our discussions appreciate it
merry christmas to you as well
okay so um basically does that make
sense that's why
you want to be careful about the move
queen a5 okay so knight f3 e6
and now knight e5 this is the key idea
of the juba without this move this
entire setup would be
less than perfect and i actually think
e6 is inaccurate i think
knight f6 might be a little bit more
accurate to leave open the possibility
of moving back for the mission
okay so just to reiterate
just to reiterate 95 bishop e5
the whole point of the line is that
bishop b5 check is a very big threat
which drives the king out of e8 so if i
were
uh chess kid i would maybe do this okay
just take and go e6
get the knight out of the center and go
a6 i know this looks a little flimsy but
you quickly develop your king's side i
think black is fine here
but after knight f6 g4 i basically am
playing on both sides of the board now
let's analyze the complications
arising after knight takes e5 okay so
d65 happens right
now let's unpack the situation as i've
advocated many times don't panic when
you see a lot going on we can
isolate the sort of separate elements of
the position that'll help you understand
what's happening no problem
knight is hanging bishop is hanging two
pieces are hanging at once
okay now both pieces can be protected at
once we can play bishop takes g4
and in the event of this move white has
several ways to win the game
could somebody propose one of them
actually you want to be very careful you
want to be accurate here
well f3 is the obvious move but bishop
b5
is the five head move check now you do
have a way to block the check but whoa
this leaves the bishop undefended and if
king e7 not only is this bad at per se
check and i win a second piece so bishop
b5 is a very strong move
knight takes g4 of course bishop b5
and in this position uh the simplest is
i think to just
kick the knight away and i know that a
lot of people are like whoa whoa this is
checkmate
this is not checkmate remember there are
three ways to deal with a check to move
the king
to take the checking piece and to block
the check
you need to check all three boxes before
you assure yourself that it's made and
here
box number two is not checked you can go
f6 and look at
the bishop on f8 that bishop is actually
very important defensive piece
because after takes takes the bishop
opens up its defense of the night you're
not winning the piece
so instead of doing something drastic
the simplest as i've advocated for the
whole speedrun is to go something like 2
and castle
do not forget to complete your
development when in doubt simply
complete the development accumulate the
pressure
and actually the move queen d2 poses a
hidden threat
what is now being threatened let's say
black plays something like rook c8
what move what can white now do and if
you guys are very attentive to
everything that this move accomplishes
battery um battery equals another
attacker
bishop takes h6 wins a piece that is one
of several things i can do
i hope that makes sense yeah so
i hope that makes sense so for that
reason
knight takes c5 doesn't work bishop e4
doesn't really help f3
bishop g6 h4 uh inducing f3 i think is
neither good nor bad for black
now black is forced to play this move h5
this allows
me to ruin black's pawn structure uh
around the king and now
immediately go after black spawn with
bishop d3 now if knight takes d4 then
bishop g6 wins the knight
okay so king f7 is basically forced now
to move g5
i want to explain this move now there is
a practical reason
why i didn't just go queen d2 and this
actually does give up a pawn now this is
not the best pawn
but i didn't want to allow this i i
didn't want to allow
this kind of avenue of play a lot of
people were suggesting rook g1 and
thinking ah let me x-ray the pun
but now h takes g4 and don't forget the
rook rook takes h4 my voice cracked
again
and black wins another pawn so the the
reason i go g5 is because
i'm temporarily closing up the king side
in order to be able to complete my
development without having to worry
about stuff happening on the king's side
so knight g82
now if knight takes d4 who can remind me
of white's
response in this position who can remind
me of what to do
and there's actually several things to
do
now bishop g6 is one move but what i
would urge people to do especially at a
higher rating if you're 2100 2200 you're
listening to this but at all levels
really
do not rush to assume that you have to
win the pawn back
consider the move castles long the fact
that black has taken the central pawn
can actually benefit white
because white's the one with two pieces
on the d-file
so these pawns on e6 and d5 they may
look imposing
but both of them are sitting ducks
particularly the e pawn
look at all of white's pieces clustered
together in the center whereas black's
pieces are barely developed
so rook he one is going to come with
devastating effect i would actually not
force things with bishop takes g6 i
think that we could get
bit we could get better than that right
so
questioning your assumptions and not
making these knee jerk response moves
is actually a element of i think chess
mastery at a higher level if that makes
sense well knight takes f3 actually does
our work for us
now we open up the f-file the queen
could come to f2 look at this look at
this
first of all the knight is trapped but
even if it wasn't bishop c7 would expose
the attack on the queen
so i want you guys to understand that
pawns in such positions when we're
aiming for checkmate
pawns can actually hurt us and
sacrificing two three punts
you need to be able to do that without a
single second thought
okay take that with a grain of salt that
i'm not advocating for throwing pawns
around and just giving them up
willy-nilly
but um in a situation like this black is
so undeveloped
that him taking another pawn is not
going to make the difference
okay i don't know if that if i'm
explaining this in a clear way
but my intuition here is just screaming
that white is completely winning there's
just no way black is going to defend
this he's got not a single piece
developed
if you just compare the development of
the pieces forget about everything else
white's got all of his pieces developed
black has literally just a knight on f3
that's it
does that make sense so bishop d6 we
castle
here again we avoid the knee-jerk
reaction we realize that the ah the
queen defends the bishop
we want him to take on f4 because then
the queen enters the game dislodges the
king from the pawn and then we play
bishop takes g6
so knight g7 bring the last piece into
the game knight f5 of course we take
that knight
and whichever way black takes he opens
up a fatal
avenue into his position if he takes f5
what is white's move
we detect the change in the position and
what do we do
simple simple uh attentiveness to
change oh yep pawn has lost its
supporter knight takes d5
and if g takes f5 we we push through
with g6 if king takes g6 this is a fork
so the king has to go away rook takes c6
and now let's fast forward
to this position now first of all queen
takes f5 i understand what people are
thinking
which is that ah this is gonna be
checkmate but remember there are three
ways to block a check to defend against
the check
moving the king taking the checking
piece
and in any order or blocking the check
so here categories two and three are
both alive we can take the checking
piece
and now we can block the check so when
you are
about to do something like this my
proposal my piece of advice
is to actually go through those three
check boxes and make sure that they are
not
checked make sure that you have
accounted for them when you literally
tell your brain
check for ways no pun intended to block
the check you're more likely to find
queen fe than if you're sort of
uh free rolling and trying to search
around so queen c7 it's the same
principle right
a lot of people look at this and say
well white is winning right because this
is checkmate
but hey is black forced to take on e8
black can just drop his rook back to c8
covering the eighth rank
and at the end of the day we're gonna be
down to rook very important
not to assume that your opponent has to
check take a piece now 97 check i really
am not sure what attracted people to
this move
because of knight takes e7 and now you
relinquish your control over the g pawn
hey black is back in the game
black is back in the game now knight e3
is good
but a little bit too slow this is good
if in the absence of other options but
knight c7 wins the game on the spot
literally because there's no defense to
rookie none zero
black can't interpose the file rook
takes c7 doesn't help queen takes c7
followed by rookie eight
the game is over how did i find this
move i used
the wishlist method i've advocated for
the wishlist method
uh a lot since i hit 2000. in such
positions you create a wish list
what is my number one ideal aspiration
what do i want for birthday what do i
want for christmas
pretty fitting example i want a rook on
e8
now am i crazy to think this is like
what we ultimately want because the rook
on ea would win his queen okay how do we
get it there
okay queen e3 comes to mind can we
employ another piece other than the
queen
because we already know the principle if
we can do something with a with a lesser
value piece
normally that's a better idea than doing
it with a queen we leave the queen for
the most important tasks and then we see
knight c7 it takes a little creativity
but knight c7 is not hard to see if we
apply that particular logical chain
okay so we've been experimenting with
various openings
holy smokes lion pride five tier one
sums thank you
let's go with another accelerated dragon
let's go with another accelerated dragon
and again he goes bishop b5 everybody
seems to be doing this at this level
now we keep the spirit of the
accelerated by playing g6
this is called the rosso limo bishop g7
damn girl thanks
eddie keeping that hype alive love it
okay so now what move have i played in
these positions
i've played kind of the same way in
these types of positions
in order to institute a bind in the
center this move seems counter-intuitive
right
because the bishop is good but we use
the bishop as a
cog in the machine and the machine is
control of the center
okay so now we get the knight to e7 we
don't want to interfere with the
bishop's control of the center
500 bits in crocodile style thank you so
much man i really appreciate it
that is a big time bomb now this is
weird
because this does give me a pawn now i
know that pawn sacrifices of these
n of this nature do exist but i'm not
really
convinced by this i'm gonna take twice
okay i'm gonna take twice
let's see what he has in store for us
yeah let's take take twice
okay so e5 now the reason that i'm
skeptical about this
way of playing is that the pawn on e5 is
itself going to be weak
and his entire his entire strategy
hinges on him being able to sustain that
pawn on e5
if the pawn is gone then his whole
position comes unglued so knight takes
d4
is is impossible really because of
knight takes e5 now i know a lot of
people probably want to go d6 at this
point
but that carries its own danger because
d6 ed6 queen d6 opens up that e file
so we might very well want to play d6
but we need to calculate we need to
ensure
that after d6 ed queen d6 and i'm
actually very skeptical i'm not even
going to engage in that i'm going to
castle
why why go for something like that when
we have a perfectly good alternative in
castling
and i know a lot of people are like wait
we can go queen b6 and attack the bishop
but let's reserve that move in case he
moves his bishop away from c1
which he does and he does that in order
to overprotect the pawn now the other
side of the board
has gotten weaker so now we can go queen
b6
and skewer the bishop to the pawn and
now we can chase the bishop away
okay so you can see the logic here in
effect now he's actually playing this in
a very interesting
way bishop d3 would be the best move for
white here
and uh this pawn is very annoying uh
it's not helping my bishop develop i
think a6 was a little hasty
so i wouldn't take the spawn the reason
i would not take this one is after
knight c4
i'll show this after the game i'll
demonstrate this but
that actually leads to some sketchy
sketchy positional play so what should
we do here
now what i want to do i want to apply an
idea that i've applied previously
i do want to get b5 in i want to play b5
in order to liberate the bishop so what
should i do
how do we where should we move the queen
so it's out of the way of the other
pieces yeah
so i've applied this idea in one of my
early speedrun games i've even showed
you and i'll show you guys again
kind of the same idea applied in one of
my games and this guy is actually
playing
legendary game right now this is going
to get very messy now we're going to
develop our bishop
this guy is playing in legendary style
right now
we're gonna have to get his pieces off
of their squares i've kind of
underestimated
some of this guy's play and he continues
to play incredibly well so
let's try to get this knight out of d6
how can we do that
how can we get this knight out of dc
well it doesn't work either
no this is actually very bad for me so
let's um
let me think about this yeah let's go
knight c8
let's let's try at least yeah all right
this is not looking good guys um
it seems it appears that i'm outmatched
here but let's see
well i i came close to losing a speedrun
game yesterday
but because these guys are now
incredibly good
guile pyle gilipili
okay let's see what he does he did hold
on to the pawn he won the battle
but will he win the war will he win the
war he has a very good move here i won't
say the move in case you're watching
stream
which i don't think so but in case he
has a really good move
he doesn't play i thought knight e4
would have been super strong
this i think gives me a chance um
because
what we have to do now is get our pieces
out of their
incredibly passive square so let's
reactivate the knight we need to get
that knight out of c8 it wasn't doing
anything
and then we need to get the rook to e8
really quickly we need to get those
pieces
pronto actually let's centralize our
knight first let's send the queen
back okay he has this move
man this guy doesn't freaking quit
um yeah this is very bad i actually
missed this
i'm losing my mind here i forgot about
this move
yeah this is probably just over let me
think
okay let's go f6 let's let's stop knight
g5 at least
no if he continues in this style it's
over but we'll uh we'll at least test
him a little bit
okay so let's see what he does bishop e4
jesus okay so now knight takes e5
knight d4 okay i kind of have to do this
i kind of have to do this
and then knight d4
f5 i'm very close to losing that on the
spot but
somehow i'm holding on can i hold on
here
yeah the problem after knight d4 is that
my knight
is irrevocably caught in this pin
it's irrevocably caught in this pin and
there's just nothing i can do
okay so he does whoa now that move
is damn girl
okay now wait let me think about this
for a second
that is an insane move um hmm
yeah that's an incredibly good move he's
not not paying attention to the
the temptation okay let's try rook a8
actually let's get the rook involved
let's get the rook involved let's
continue testing him
guys no accusations please we've been
through this many times
let's move the king out of the way
otherwise he was threatening a discovery
guys until we checked the game
you must allow the possibility that i
simply got outplayed which is
which i've which i have gotten outplayed
and
these people are no longer you know this
these games are all very competitive and
i've been playing all day i'm a little
bit tired so i'm
for fully allowing the possibility that
that i got outplayed he's spending
a lot of time here and i think he's
playing
legit chess so this is this does not
look like a
oh my god but he's got this move holy
smokes some of these ideas he's finding
are just
incredible okay let me think
so let's go here actually let's go f5
i will check the game i check every game
that i am on the cusp of losing i
i uh advance i understand that it is
unlikely that i get outplayed
wholeheartedly by like a 2300 but
unlikely does not mean we throw out
accusations
okay so we're losing a piece but
actually i have two pawns for that piece
so
if he takes my rook um i'm going to try
to flag him here
although it's not going to be easy but i
will try to flag him um
let's see knight f3 that's another
cold-blooded and incredibly strong move
let's drop the queen back
let's drop the queen back
okay now he's he's very slow and
what we're going to do here and by the
way piece of advice
if you're trying to flag someone the
best way to do it is to do something
like this right you go into this long
end game
and what you try to do you don't make
any pre-moves you just
you hope you try to stay alive as much
as possible
you you get a couple seconds here a
couple seconds there
and you want to confuse him so what i'm
trying to do is confuse him make him
calculate some moves
okay make him calculate some moves make
him calculate row k6
and okay he's spending like a couple
seconds per move so
i'm trying to slowly bleed out some of
his clock okay now he has to look about
rook h7 does he play it
now we need next step is to get him
below 20 seconds
he's gonna check me
okay no he's not now we need to run we
run with the king
because i know that that way i'm going
to avoid checkmate
for a long time although here i'm going
to go king f6 verifying first
okay now we bleed some more clock we
bleed some more clock now we pin him
you see bleeding more clock check
bleeding more cluck
and he did not get himself checkmated
which was actually possible but he's not
gonna make it because he's just spending
i don't understand what he's doing but
he literally is just going to sit this
one out
okay now i'm already in the game okay
so that's how you flag these guys
and let's i will check the accuracy
obviously it'll be lowered by the
low quality at the end of the game i
mean this is what it is
so we see 96.2 for us
91.7 very high quality game overall i
mean
very high quality game overall and um
it see what this tells you is that this
doesn't really address
how the game usually goes like you can
be losing
and your accuracy per se can be higher
than your opponent so
let's actually look at the game i mean
let's let's see
so let me close it okay so why did i get
in trouble now i
won a very similar game to this myself
that's kind of funny with white
i think this is actually a mistake
so what happens here this move d4
uh this is exactly how i sacrificed upon
what this basically does uh
and and in order to understand
everything you need to understand
uh that the battle revolves around the
d6 square and you guys might be looking
at this what are you talking dc what
does this have to do with anything
okay well what this has to do with
everything is that you guys see this
bishop right
this bishop needs to get developed right
if i don't develop this bishop
my entire queen side is dead right dead
and uh in order to develop the queen
side effectively i have to be able to
play d6 but if white gets a piece onto
d6 then
it's going to be an elephant sitting on
me i won't be able to move my pieces
around it's like the artery will be
sliced between the queenside and
kingside
and that in effect is the idea of d4
what white is trying to do is carve out
this maneuver that i have drawn on the
board or
this maneuver both of which result in a
piece getting put on d6 or both
okay now why can't black take
this way and then this way this would be
possible
but in this position how can white
prevent black from castling
and by the way e5 would slice the bishop
off of
its base it's like a roomba that's
gotten under the bed
and uh it turns off right you can't get
the bishop back to you
i think this is even stronger than
bishop h6 the computer indicates bishop
h
bishop h6 is the best move that would
also be possible you can't get this
bishop out of here look at this
incredibly annoying bishop you can't
castle
white's gonna get a knight to d5 he's
gonna start encircling you
bishop takes b2 same principle that i
just outlined
i don't care about these pieces take all
of them
because look at black's position look at
the development
and now knight c4 knight d6 is basically
just checkmate
beautiful by the way look at this and
i'll show you my game after this to give
you some context into how this stuff
happens
so for that reason i played knight 64
and uh
for that reason i played cd ed but now
he goes e5
and the reason that d6 is not good
is something like bishop g5 he just puts
this guy on there
and look at all of these pins
crisscrossing the board now if d takes
e5
what move does white play tactically
speaking can
white recapture the pawn on e5 and i
want you guys to pay very careful
attention
to these two pins which means that both
knights are immobilized
which means immobilized means that this
knight isn't actually defending that
pawn
knight e5 exposes both pins bishop takes
c5 rook takes e5
and if black castles then bishop takes
c6 picks off the knight
does that make sense this would be an
illustrative example of how d6 just
doesn't work that's why i need to castle
but guess what that comes at a price
that price is that now
d6 or d5 are impossible that just
blunders upon
so i decided to play on the other side
of the board but what i didn't realize
this move knight a3 is super good i
missed this i missed this move
it defends the bishop and simultaneously
prepares what potential maneuver
what potential maneuver is prepared by
the move knight a3 aren't knights on the
rim grim like why is he doing this
who can tell me yeah knight c4 knight t6
right once this knight is slammed onto
d6 it's actually incredibly similar guys
insanely similar to a game that i had
with the white pieces which i'm about to
show you
and by the way this is actually insane
now um
this is already like losing for black
this is like literally losing i
literally cannot move
and what he now does is he just says i'm
going to checkmate you
now here i think he missed a winning
move and i just checked the computer he
had a winning move in this position
this winning move is very hard to see
in order to see it i need you guys to
understand the concept of
transforming the advantage right now
there is this chest aphorism that good
positions don't win the game good moves
with the game
we play to win the game so an
outpost in and of itself and you guys
are actually seeing the move you
freaking
beasts knight e4 the outpost has done
its job
now we need to get the knight to f6 and
the bishop to h6 and literally just go
for checkmate
look at all of black species just
visually clustered on the queen side
so we immediately switch our efforts to
the king side that's how i won
my game and this is entirely unstoppable
this is like plus five already
this move wins on the spot so
yeah so knight c8 he takes on b7 what
he's trying to do is he tries to
eliminate my strongest piece
and then he's trying to go for checkmate
so his idea also makes sense
but it's not the best okay so i get my
knight out of the doldrums
but now i send this queen to h4 now he
has this very grand prix attack style
idea of piling up on the h7 pawn
which is why i played f6 stopping knight
g5 but now
he goes bishop e4 skewering my knights i
mean look how nasty this is 95 is forced
and now rook 81 what he basically says
this is the worst kind of pin the pin
against the queen
i cannot stop him from taking on d4 and
literally just winning the night
okay do you want me guys to show you an
example
of how 94 leads to checkmate i would
literally now show you my game
because i've made very much such a
maneuver and it led to checkmate so let
me show you my game
which will help you then understand how
these kinds of positions
lead to checkmate let me demonstrate and
i'm not trying to flex this is truly
very pertinent you guys will see how
similar the positions were they were
almost identical
now this game that i'm about to show you
is from the tournament after i became a
gm
i was playing a very strong grand master
from ukraine
i was playing a very strong grandmaster
from ukraine
and i was able to win a really really
nice game
and uh i annotated it so you guys can
see nerdy ski against
andre waff 2581 so uh very competent
very strong gm
and i was 2503 feet at that point i had
just because i just got my third norm uh
in the tournament before and i was
riding the
i was riding a high i mean i was just
really confident and i played another
really good tournament
so we can see same line and here i
played c3 so slightly different mover
he goes e5 guess what i do guys knight
a3
knight c4 and d4 literally the same
thing exact same pawn sacrifice
and i get my knight to d6 so just
uncannily similar and what i did
i'm literally sitting on him rook a7
rookie c1 i played very patiently here
and eventually what happened
is this position okay this position
happened
and i have basically made all the
necessary improvements in my position
it is now time to transform the
advantage and if i
was able to do that and my opponent was
able to do that 1984
there is an even better way of getting
the knight into the attack and that is
which move it's not knight e4 although
that is fine
which very pretty move gets the knight
into the attack
think g-file guys boom
knight f5 if g takes f5 bishop h6
and because f6 is not possible checkmate
is unstoppable
so what i do here is i take the bishop
and by taking the bishop
i leave his king completely exposed
and black tries knight takes e5 very
interesting tactical idea
queen e3 and i just drove his king out
bishop takes f6 here
bishop takes f6 by the way this move
knight takes e5 that he made is really
interesting
if bishop takes c5 he goes queen takes
e5 and because of the back
rank this actually just liquidates in
black's favor
so instead i patiently move my queen
away now bishop f6
queen takes c1 queen h6 tightening the
noose around the king
and now i drove his king out if king g7
then rookie 7 finishes the game
so boom boom boom and he resigned here
because it is checkmate in two moves
check and queen g3 is checkmate so you
guys can see
along very similar lines i chose the
right moment to
exit the outpost right and this leads
very quickly to the toppling of his
the last remaining defensive piece and
his king becomes essentially defenseless
okay so transitioning back to the
speeder and hopefully now you guys can
better understand the sort of zen behind
this move now knight f5 here doesn't
actually work
although it can be considered but knight
e4 comes with a very similar idea you're
trying to involve the knight in the
attack
and ultimately to trade this bishop so
the way that he played was perfectly
good as well and ultimately he ends up
winning the piece so f4 is a really good
move by him
he attacks the knight if i move the
knight he has bishop takes g6
with checkmate unstoppable because he's
also attacking the rook
and uh for that reason i had to give up
the knight he's completely winning here
we won't look at the rest of the game he
correctly traded queens and
basically he did everything well up
until the very end
um yeah if the queen was on g4 then
knight f5 so literally you can see the
similarity between these two games it's
the timing i really struggle with
one kind of good heuristic is have i
made the necessary improvements
right have i made the necessary
improvements here look at how white has
brought
basically most of his pieces into the
attack
so most of his pieces are in the attack
which means okay now we can switch
to frontal attack 94 isn't such a big
risk either it's not like you're
sacrificing a rook or something you're
just
bringing another piece into the attack
so you shouldn't think of this as such a
committal decision or anything of that
nature
well my movie five was a mistake i think
so
somewhere here or maybe somewhere here i
should have actually been bitten the
bullet and got d5
i don't know probably i should have done
this
and after it takes takes uh if he goes
bishop g5 here then i can castle maybe i
can get away with this
so i don't know these lines too well so
this bishop b5 is super super dangerous
for that exact reason
that's another lesson to be very careful
about playing these kinds of openings
when you don't know exactly what you're
doing my bad i i
do try to answer every question but
sometimes i miss them i bet
so e takes f6 i don't know well i think
knight takes f6 helps black because this
brings my knight into the game and it
defends h7
so it's actually a good thing this
knight on d5 is like a sitting duck
right white uses it as a tool
to bring another piece into the game
with tempo e-takes f6 would actually
help this knight
maneuver back into the defense straw man
asks oh yeah queen takes b2 so why
didn't i take on b2
back in this position and can i also
show the idea of a6 queen a7 how did i
know about this idea i'll show that as
well
so knight c4 comes with tempo and after
queen before
uh the sad reality ladies and gentlemen
is that
he can even go knight d6 again you guys
might think
oh he's coupon sound i don't give a
knight is on d6
the fact that black has two on one here
could not matter less if black is going
to get checkmated
so maybe i should have done this anyway
and bitten the bullet
but um it was very dejecting to just get
the knight to d6